[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
applications in cancer research rna
isolation from organoids and spheroids
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
laura chapman r d manager thermo fisher
scientific
anna priya gupta scientist level 2
thermo fisher scientific
and j bhandari scientist level 2 thermo
fisher
scientific laura onopria and jay you may
now begin your presentation
thank you and thanks everyone for
joining today and we're excited to
present to you um some of the research
that we've been doing here
at thermo fisher's scientific
to start off with i just wanted to give
a quick intro slide to our speakers
today so
my name is laura chapman and i'm an r d
manager
and i've been with thermo fisher
scientific for 16 years so quite a quite
a while and i've worked on several
different things listed here under my
picture
um
and today we're going to be focusing on
steroids and organoids we also have
anupria gupta joining us and she's been
here for a few years and has some
experience with our kingfisher and duo
um flex and duo platforms for um
automation
for sample prep and then
lastly is jay bhandari he'll be
presenting lastly he's got extensive
background and lots of cancer research
as well as uh here at thermo fisher
supporting our products and generating
lots of data to
highlight some of the applications for
those
so thank you again for joining us
so this is a brief overview of our
agenda for today uh we'll give an
introduction into cancer cancer research
and then an introduction to organoids
and steroids and then we'll move into
some more of the data that we've
generated here
for rna isolation from those 3d cell
cultures um using
um standard spin columns or trisol as
well as some of our higher throughput
using like the kingfischer flex the duo
and also a lysate-based method with
celsius et
so again thanks for joining us and i
just wanted to give some high-level
cancer statistics
the cancer
is a burden worldwide
it's among the leading cause of death uh
for the entire world
and um just if you look at the cases
from 2018 and then by 2040 it's almost
double so in about 20 years we'll have
almost
double the number of cancer cases
that are diagnosed
and so interestingly i put on this third
note the cancer rates are highest among
those countries that are well educated
and
have the highest life expectancy however
some cancers are the opposite and the
poorer countries and um
such as cervical cancer these are much
higher rates in the poorer countries and
so it's quite interesting just due to
differences in economic availability of
medicines
so this is some more
some data high level data for cancer and
how it affects general population this
is specific to the united states
interestingly breast cancer is about 15
of the new cases diagnosed as shown in
the dark blue pie on the left side
however if you look at that dark blue
pie on the right side it's only about
seven percent of the deaths
and this is due to the amount of
research and early detection that's
been encouraged for breast cancer
diagnosis and early detection is the
main thing is like preventing
so you can see that with the amount of
survival uh comparing the diagnosis
versus the the number of deaths
again if you look at prostate cancer
it's about 14 of the new cases that are
diagnosed as shown
in the green however if you look at the
death it doesn't even show up in the
death so that's quite interesting as
well and again it's because of early
detection and the progress that we've
made with researching these cancers
however if you look at the lung and
bronchitis cancers those are 12 of the
new cases yet 21
um die from
bronchus and lung cancers so this is
highlighting an area where more research
is needed
and then some other interesting data
that i wanted to highlight this is by
gender again in the united states
breaking down the different cancers that
are diagnosed with males and females
if you look at the
males the number one type of cancer that
is diagnosed is prostate cancer and then
for females the number one diagnosed is
breast cancer and breast cancer is
actually the number one diagnosed of all
cancers between males and females
once you get past those then it's pretty
even there's not a huge difference
between genders as to which cancer
diagnosis is received except for uterine
which is
primarily for a female
so
anyway this is just highlighting some of
the cancers that are
pop in the united states but also need
some more research and some great links
have been made in the research space and
some new ways of researching is using 3d
cell culture
some of you may be familiar
with organoids and steroids but for
those who are not i wanted to give a
brief introduction as to what 3d cell
culture is and a definition of what
we've been calling spheroids and
organoids there's a little bit of um
still discussion as to what an organoid
or a spheroid actually is and so this is
the way that we've defined what an
organoid and spheroid is
so spheroids are
more simple they are 3d cell aggregate
aggregates generally one cell type is
the um all that is self-assembled
within a cell culture vessel um
or some kind of environment they can be
grown in different ways using something
like major gel or just in a non-adherent
cell plate
and they typically like i said they're
typically only one cell type generally
you don't require scaffolding for
spheroids but you can put some matrigel
in the media or you can
have them grown on major gel dots
however
some people just have them grow in
non-adherent plates
the other type of 3d culture that we'll
be talking about today are organoids and
these are much more complex
they're 3d as well multicellular
generally different types of cells go
into the structures that create these
organoids
they are grown in vivo to mimic the
parallel organ
that would be found in vivo sorry
they're grown in vitro to parallel the
organ found in vivo
they can be derived from stem cells
either ispcs or escs
and they generally take weeks to
differentiate into those organoids and
today's data will be using midbrain
organoids that were differentiated by
some of our colleagues here in thermo
fisher scientific starting from
some escs that were differentiated down
a path to create midbrain organoids so
that's the um the type of organoids that
we used here and then for steroids we
had a few different
cells that we used to create the
spheroids for testing and so with that
i'll pass it over to anupria who will
take over for the next section
thank you for the introduction laura i
just wanted to talk a little bit about
3d culture and add to some of the things
that laura has already mentioned
so like she said
they present an invisible picture for
something that is in vitro so we're able
to grow
organoids or steroids from
primary tissues or in moderate
immortalized cell lines or
and they resemble an in vivo pattern due
to adhesion that's their primary thing
monolayer cells stick to the bottom of
the plate and
3d cell cultures spheros and organoids
generally stick to each other
with adhesion and the advantage over
monolayer here we have is for cancer
research drug discovery and toxicity
testing
so here we are looking at some
immortaliser line
sphero generation that we grew in lab
these are hebg2 cells
these cells were played
diluted and plated in a 96 well plate
and from anywhere from 500 to 16 000
cells and they were spun down
after being plated and that's where you
see the uh day zero
uh congregation of cells together but as
they start to grow in media which was 10
fps and dmem uh you can see that they
clamped together pretty tightly and
start to get really really big
and uh grow on top of each other in a 3d
format again these don't adhere to the
bottom of the plate they are due to each
other and they're grown in non-adherent
plates
um so anywhere from one to seven days
you can see a pretty linear
um growth
here i'm going to mostly cover four uh
kits that are commercially available
on our website um and they kind of go
left to right in um
the amount of hands on the reduction in
hands-on time and the increase in a
scalability slash uh the amount of
samples that you can run
um so on the on the left here we have
trisol
it's a chloral phenol chloroform
extraction
has
a lot of
yields a very very pure and clean sample
spin columns everybody uses them
everybody's familiar with them
it works with the filter and you
centrifuge your sample down
crude lysate which is direct lysis into
qpcr
only seven minutes of license time
and then magnetic beads which can be put
on a instrument so that you do some
hands-on uh processing early on and then
you put all the downstream
uh washes wash steps and illusion onto a
machine and that's magbeam based
tries all through marvana all of these
kits are available on our website
um so let's talk a little bit about
trisol and purelink
these two tips have been around for
decades and people use them all the time
and there's
uh familiar results and you it's it's
consistent and it's purity but the only
issue is that with trisol you have some
hazardous material so you need to work
in the hood and a high hands-on time so
you're sitting by the centrifuge and
watching your sample spin down and it's
generally low throughput due to the fact
that it is very high hands on time
all right let's look at some data
concerning uh serves an organized when
extracted with the trisol kit uh so
these steroids that you're seeing on the
top left in the picture they were grown
for 48 hours
heb g2 spirit and after two washes with
pbs once the media was removed 25
microliters of pbs was left
uh prior to extraction
um when you look at the chart on the
bottom there's uh
average cts on the y-axis and the number
of seated cells per steroid on the
x-axis so we're going from 500 to 16 000
and you can see that there is quite a
bit of variability with the triazole
extraction
we may have possibly lost a little bit
of cellular material looking at the 2000
and the 16 000
data sets and that's why you see a lot
of variability
um
in the error bars
for organoids on the right there's
average cd on y-axis and the number of
samples
on the x-axis so
the left bars are trisol and the right
bars
red and black are eight organoids
pulled together and then extracted and
you can see that there is about a
3.3 ct difference
when you pull eight organoids together
so we can see linear recovery
on the bottom it's an agilent trace um
agilent uh isn't it that's an
electrophorogram and you can see that
the triazole gives pretty good rin
values at 9.4
now we're going to look at some pure
links thin column rna extractions so
again these are 48 hours of
g2 steroids left with 25
25 microliters of pbs left in the well
and you can see a pretty significant
linearity in the
number of seated cells
going from 500 to 16 000
that's average ct's on the y-axis and
seated cells on the x-axis
and on the right that's a representative
picture of an ipsc spheroid
um and the orange bars
show that uh we added a xeno as a
positive control internally and you can
see that there is no
xeno inhibition therefore all of these
samples are pure and without inhibition
looking um at the bottom graph
we compared the extractions of one and
two spheroids so we wanted to see if
there was linear recovery and you can
see that it's about a cd shift downwards
just two spheres and that also indicates
uh linearity
here are some of the
organoids these are midbrain organoids
that are grown for six weeks uh in
suspension while while shaking and then
they were shipped to us um overnight
in a hibernate medium but they were not
frozen um you can see that there are
pretty significant differences in
morphology and because these organoids
are more tissue like
they're very tightly bound and it's
pretty difficult to lyse them so
whatever our standard method of lysis is
we had to add a two or three minutes
extra on the vortexer and maybe a little
bit of pipetting to make sure that we
were able to get efficient lysis
um on the bottom with the blue graphs
you uh with the blue bars you can see
that that's uh average ct on the y axis
and um
three
housekeeping genes on the x-axis cdk gne
and gpi and we can see pretty pretty
good cts
uh with the pure link extraction
um
the ring values for purelink on the
agilent trace is a little bit lower at
6.9 but still pretty
uh decent
recovery and quality
and with that i will pass this over to
jay
thank you
that was really good intro to our gold
standard methods for rna isolation using
swords and organoids
again my name is jay bandari and i'm one
of the application scientists here at
thermal fischer scientific
in the next few slides i'll introduce
some of the automated and high
throughput extraction methods for these
3d cultures
and present some experimental data for
rna isolation for swords and organoids
using these methods
so our automated extraction methods
utilize magnetic bead based purification
so magnetic beads
offer many benefits compared to
traditional methods for isolating total
rna
compared to any other organic extraction
using trisol that only priya mentioned
earlier are a spin column based
extraction
with pure link
rna mini so magnetic beads bind rna
which enables higher and more consistent
yields and more
reproducible data
uh let me begin by
introducing our magmax mirvana total rna
isolation kit
the kit uses
magnetic e-based technology and is
designed
for the isolation of total rna including
small rnas such as micrornas from a wide
variety of sample types
the kit is optimized for use with
multiple sample types
which could be
serum plasma
whole blood
tissue
cell culture and urine in other words
there is no need to order special kits
for each of the sample size so one kit
for the most the diverse set of samples
with the magnetic bead-based
purification you can scale from
processing 6 to 96 samples at once when
combined with the
kingfisher instruments which could be
kingfisher duo
kingfisher duo prime kingfisher flex or
kingfisher apex
so alternatively alternatively you can
also use
or you can process your samples manually
the magnetic stand
so in terms of workflow magnetic b based
extraction can be divided into three
basic steps
the prepare plates with samples and
reagents
typical pre-processing steps
run a program on a kingfisher instrument
the instrument can be either of those
like i discussed earlier
which can run
like kingfisher duo which can run up to
24 samples at once
or kingfisher apex or kingfisher flex
10k that can actually run up to
96 samples
after you run a program then you collect
the total rna at the end at their one
which could uh depend on your depending
on your sample type it could either be
60 minutes 75 minutes are either
one and a half hours
and the benefit of using automated
extraction is that it reduces your
hands-on time significantly compared to
more traditional methods like trisol or
peerlink
to put that into perspective with
purelink and trisol it will probably
take you about two or three hours to
process the samples
from start to finish and you will be
constantly working on the patch
with magnetic beads
and kingfisher automation
your hands-on time is significantly
reduced
the total turnaround time is
for sauce is about
75 minutes but the total hands-on time
for pre-processing and setting up the
plates is only about 20 minutes
for
tissues
the total turnaround time is about 90
minutes but the total hands-on time is
approximately about 35 minutes so
automation definitely helps to use your
hands on time
let's look at rna isolation from
different spirits using this magmax
marijuana tool rna isolation kit
on the top left here
you can see the steroids
from hep g2 cells
the spheroids were formed by the
addition of various number of cell
inputs
as shown here on the top and grown for
48 hours
the scale bars on the bottom shows the
average diameter of the spheres from
different adjectives cell input
after four years are 48 hours of growth
so we took these individuals forwards
from formed on a 96 wall plate
and washed them with
pbs and used the cell
lysis and binding protocol from the
magmax nirvana total rna isolation kit
and at the end of the run on the
kingfisher instrument we do get a clean
rna and the diluted rna was used to
compare gene expression of some of the
common housekeeping genes
like the kinase is mentioned here using
the
rt cube here
the graph here shows the average cycling
threshold or ct values on y-axis and
number of cells seeded per squared on
the x-axis
a single sword was used for uh
for
extraction in this experiment and we can
see that there is a linear recovery of
ct values from the spirit generated
from different cell numbers
on the top right you can see we looked
at spirits generated from use thoropodan
stem cells or ipscs
these were significantly larger
in size compared to have g2 cells have
spirits on the left
performed an extraction using a magmax
nirvana
kit and looked at gene expression
profiles from these
spheroids
we also included an internal positive
control are the geneal rna spiking
controls to compare the performance of
the kit
and check
for rna inhibition from these samples
and we saw the expected ct values for
genome expression
suggesting the absence of inhibition
from rna isolated
from these
ipsc spheroids
so this suggests that magmax nirvana kit
can efficiently be used to isolate spurs
from ipscs and also from like hedgie two
cultured cells
we then compared
efficiency of the kit for multiples
forwards
basically we asked couple of questions
so one
can we apply magmax marijuana for our
nice relation from multiples fluids
are
two do we get consistent recovery of rna
and the answer to both is yes
you can use macromax nirvana for our
isolation from two's words and we do get
linear recovery of gene expression
and for these experiments we actually
use cell and put up 500 5000 cells first
fluid um
and as expected the ct difference for
these unit targets expressed in
individuals storage versus a pool of two
swords
was approximately approximately about
one cycle
to summarize our findings uh we say that
our magmax total rna isolation kit
was able to efficiently isolate rna from
swords for gene expression studies
next we also looked at rna isolation
from organoids
so organoids like another organ like 3d
cell culture that
my colleagues actually talked about
earlier so we used
human midbrain organoids again these
organoids are slightly larger in size
you have some strict growth requirements
so we tested these org nodes with the
kit
the magmax nirvana kit chemistry
to begin with we found that the
pre-processing states mainly the lysis
step in particular is a little
challenging for these sample types
so we did have to modify the recommended
protocol to enable
complete license of these organoids
we increase the lysis time to two to
three minutes on a vortexer to get
complete lysis and rest of the protocol
was similar to that used for rna
isolation from spheroids
so these isolated rna was used to study
gene expression and as you can see
we do get good ct values for the
housekeeping genes shown here on the
bottom left
so one thing of note here is that we did
see difference in gene expression
profile from human midbrain organoids
which were cultured using two different
growth conditions
so there is
always
it is important to optimize your rna
isolation which is suitable for the
different 3d cell culture
that your lab is working on suitable for
your growth conditions and your
experimental needs
to ensure that the extraction protocols
produced high quality rna and did not
reduce rna integrity we also analyzed
the quality of rna isolated from
individual organoids
using the agilent bioanalyzer
so the electrophilogram traces indicated
that high quality rna could be isolated
with minimal loss of integrity as shown
here by win value or rna integrity
number of 8.7
so the total rna including some from
small rnas was more
efficiently isolated with the magmax
chemistry
and then the isolation
here in the purple box highlights
significant recovery of small
to
rnas
we can say that automated extraction
using magnetic beat-based uh magmax
nirvana tool rna isolation kit
is efficient for rna isolation from
these 3d cultures and significantly
releases your hands on time
so in the next
section of the presentation i'll shoot
my topic and present an
efficient high throughput rna isolation
from
spheroids and organoids mainly i'll
introduce salsa ct
basically solves the ct kit allows us to
study gene expression
by real time qpcr
without rna purifications these are
available in both pacman and cyber green
detection chemistries
so these kits provide a complete
workflow for gene expression studies
directly from cultured soil cells
providing a user with excellent
performance and also reliable results
in terms of the total time the sample
prep time is only about seven minutes
for these kits
in terms of workflow
once you have your culture cells wash
them with pbs prepare lysis solution
with dna add your license solution to
the cells
pipe it and mix five times and then
incubate the cells for five minutes
then you add your stop solution and
pipette mix five times and incubate at
room temperature for two additional
minutes
and from this stage you could choose one
of the two steps for processing samples
you could do a two-step workflow where
you can take your lysate reverse
transcribe to get cdna and use that cdna
to do quantitative pcr to study gene
expression
or
you could also follow a one-step
workflow where you can go directly from
your cell lysade into your qpgr for gene
expression study
so both the rt and qpcr are performed in
a single step
so how do you decide which workflow to
choose depends on your research needs
so you can choose one step if you have
many sample types
with one sorry if you have many samples
with one or few targets
and if you do not like to store your
cdna
but
you would probably like the two-step
workflow if you have multiple targets
quantified from cdna and need higher
sensitivity for rear transcripts and
also you keep your archive your cdna
so we then looked at rna isolation from
spirits and organoids using this same
workflow
and for the experiments presented here
we performed a one-step workflow to look
at gene expression studies
so again
images of on the of the head g2 spirits
were grown for
48 hours like we did
talk about earlier with various cell
input and you can see that the average
ct values indicate a linear recovery of
rna from
fg2 spheroids
we also looked at spheres generated from
ipscs and these were significantly
larger compared to head g2 on the left
we performed an extraction using soft ct
kit and looked at gene expression
profile from these photos
we also included the geno rna spiking
control and we do see no rna inhibition
from these samples
and we do get expected ct values for
genome expression
we then compare the efficiency of the
kit for multiple screws and as expected
you do see a
difference of one cycle um between one
storage versus two square square
with same cell input
so we then looked at rna isolation from
primary hepatocyte steroids
so the average diameter of these primary
fatticide stewards
which were grown
from 1500 cells for five days was uh
approximately
approximately around 300 microns
and these are uh slightly smaller
the license efficiency of the
self-cp kit actually dependent on how
much pbs
can be removed after washing these
fluids so to test the effect of pbs
volume on isolation of rna and gene
expression
we extracted rna from these food samples
with various amounts of pbs remaining on
the plate
and then the average ct values
we recover were lower but less variable
when the initial samples contain lower
volume of pbs such as
10 microliter but if you can remove all
the pbs that will probably give you a
better gene expression profile
for your sphere words
so this actually suggested that the
larger volume of pbs probably is
influencing your lysis efficiency
therefore removal of excess pbs is
critical for
gene expression studies from these 3d
cultures
also the smaller size of the primary
hepatocyte cultures may have contributed
to
additional variability in extraction
efficiency
just because these were difficult to
work with like you you cannot um
keep them intact while
taking your pbs
out of the plate so
remove the pbs as much as you can just
to get better expression profile but be
careful that you're not losing your
sword at the same time
and also this would also suggest that
pooling smaller
size spirit cultures may minimize
uh heterogeneity and produce consistent
recovery
from these steroids
on the graphs here on the bottom right
uh you can see that there is a
difference in gene expression profiles
for primary hepatocytes taken from
three independent donors suggesting
there is a donor to donor variability
for gene expression as well so it's
critical to choose
your primary hepatocytes
at the beginning to work for your
downstream analysis
we then looked at organoid isolation
using our cell ct kit
again these were human membrane
organoids and a little challenging to
work with
for these experiments we use single
organoids
for these organoids you know in order to
achieve complete lysis again the samples
had to be vortex for two to three
minutes and the license time was
extended from five minutes to seven or
eight minutes in order to
achieve a complete lysis of the samples
on the graphs here at the bottom you can
see a good gene expression of
housekeeping genes from these organoids
what is not shown here is the
rna inhibition from these sample types
using ginormous packing controls
basically there was no
inhibition
rna inhibition from these sample types
so we can we can say that cells to ct
can be used for iron isolation from
these
cultures but you do need to
modify some of the recommended protocol
for this
and
optimize experiments for your research
needs
and up to this point i have talked about
uh each of these methods in isolation
but how do they compare so how do i
decide which ones to choose
what is the experimental data
against
of these keys
in order to compare the efficiency of
each of the methods for our isolation
we isolated rna from these samples side
by side
and here you can see on the graph on the
left
you do get consistent recovery of rna
and gene expression
from spin column based pure link rna
mini and also the
magnetic based magmax nirvana
shown here by consistent recovery of the
average ct value
itself to ct so higher ct values for low
cell input but so with consistent
recovery compared to pure link and
magmax
nirvana for high cell input steroids
organic-based trisol extraction did
recover good rna but was more variable
and less consistent out of the four
methods we tested
so for rna isolation compared between
four extraction methods from human
midbrain organoids there was a
consistent recovery of gene expression
from all the four methods that we tested
however i do want to point out here that
modifications of the workflow had to be
done to get
a complete license of these 3d cultures
however our results so that with slight
modification
you can actually get rna recovery from
3d cultures
using any of the four methods
uh it is also critical to completely
remove pbs from the samples
to increase license efficiency
particularly for soft society
and also um
again
deciding on which methods you should
choose for your research needs uh it
also depends on what your downstream
analysis would be
so
here what i would like to say or point
out is how do you choose a product for
your research so how do you decide which
ones to go with
so basically a selection of an
appropriate extraction method actually
depends on any end user requirements
and also a particular experiment and
whether a manual
or low throughput or a semi-automated
workflow is desired
so
right off the bat self the ct would be
ideal for high throughput users
who need to process individual sword and
organoid samples for gene expression
studies but you do need to modify
your protocol according to your needs
pure link mini kit or trisol might be
preferable to users who process
less than 24 samples at once
and magmax nirvana total rna isolation
kit which is a magnetic bead-based
extraction
will be compatible with high throughput
purification of rna and also dna
so it is pre
favored by end users with ngs and qpcr
workflow
extraction with trisol may be desired if
you're
pulling multiple spheres or organoids or
have to be pulled like if you need to
get
a really good gene expression profile
from small
skewers
and again each of the methods do
actually come with a
really good rna extraction
or good quality rna for your non-stem
assets depending on what your needs are
so next i'll briefly talk about the
micro rna analysis using our substance
ct kit
uh this may also be relevant to some of
our audience in the call today
micro rnas are small non-coding
rna molecules that play major roles in
post-transcriptional regulation of gene
expression
and there is always a an interest in
research in micro rnas because of their
association with cancer
in order to study microrna from cultured
cells again the experiments present here
is with cultured cells and not with the
3d cultures
we can use cell lysate from south cct
just like i talked about earlier for 3d
cultures
the only modification was that we
increased the license time from five
minutes to eight minutes
to get
complete lysis and recovery of
small rnas or micrornas
once you get the lysate you can use
tacman microrna to reverse transcribe
single microrna or use advanced microrna
assay to first transcribe
multiple micrornas
using universal reverse transcription
primers which will then go into your key
feature reaction for microrna expression
studies
so here you can see on the two graphs
here on the right with two different
cell types you do get accurate and
robust measurement of microrna which can
be achieved with any of the two
workflows you choose to study microrna
with
so if you if you would like to learn
more about the methods we discussed for
our isolation from spheroids and
organoids
please visit our website for additional
resources we also have an application
node for
studying
microrna
how do you go about studying micro rna
from cultured cells using salsa ct
furthermore there are additional
resources on the web
for salsa city with links to how to
videos
previous webinars presentations tips and
tricks
application notes technical blading
flyers and much more
with that i'd like to thank everybody
who joined this webinar today and thank
you very much for your participation
we would take any questions that you may
have thank you everyone
thank you laura ana priya and jay for
your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
which method would you recommend for
pooling multiple organoids
um i'll take a quick stab at that so for
pooling um since it's a larger number of
samples and a larger you know mass of
cells you would want something that has
a little bit stronger lysis so you
wouldn't want to use the cells to ct
that's going to be better for smaller
sample input
so trisol is a good option for low
throughput high purity if you want to do
like rna sequencing and qpcr downstream
you'll have really pure rna
to be able to do any of your downstream
analysis you could also use
the spin column method with the purelink
rna spin columns
or even
the mic max mirvana however that one has
a smaller license volume so it would
depend on the amount that you want to
cool whether that would work
very well or not probably you know if
it's a larger number of samples you
would want to use either trisol or the
spin column pure link
rna total kit um if it's a smaller
number of one or two then you could you
know maybe even up to five depending on
the total size
you could use the magmax murbani kit if
you wanted a higher throughput solution
all right thank you
next question
which method would you recommend for
screening 96 well plates
i can take that uh so
first uh first of all uh with the
spirits that you make you typically tend
to use a 96 well plate um
but you can also do it uh in a larger
batch and a flask
if you're using a 96 well plate to grow
your spirits we would recommend uh
either the mac max marijuana for
magnetic bead based extraction
or you could also go with the
salsa ct kit
which offers you a sample to solution
and has like high throughput options
would be able to screen for single
swords
grown on a 96 well plate so it kind of
depends on
whether you want to get your results
sooner
or whether you have the
capacity to do a automated extraction
using the magnetic
bead-based extraction
either of the two would be a good fit
for those
all right
and we will wrap up with that question
thank you laura and apria and jay do you
have any final comments for our audience
i would just like to say thank you for
your time we've really enjoyed sharing
some of the research that we've done
here if you have any other questions
feel free to reach out and send those
along and we can get back to you with
answers
but thank you for your time this we've
really appreciated and enjoyed sharing
it with you
thank you thank you
thank you again laura anna priya and jay
for your time today and your wonderful
presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you